bella ragazza e poi meno che questo
video sono fa vigenti oggi siamo sul
ring game quanti cazzo di game ci sono
di questa serie praticamente rentato
questo è un figo ma qual è morto oh
cazzo ha ucciso delle persone ma
seriamente questa cosa è già bellissimo
e non siamo neanche parti è un mio amico
mi sa se il mio idolo
ragazzi siamo solo in lei in the game
praticamente sarebbe il continuo ancora
di the game
quello che ho fatto ma ci sono un
miliardo ed è l'ultimo della serie non
potevano farlo e quindi ragazzi devono
iniziare starhub al press space replay
game
oh mio dio ancora questa merda certo
ogni volta che gioca sta roba mi faccio
st domande effettivamente cioè il bello
è che mi semi mi capiscono anche i
creatori di sto gioco fantastico
comunque si tratta sempre difficile
sibello è tutto uguale al capitolo
precedente
non avevo dubbi proprio pressioni che tu
continui art the game
vabbè proviamo questo video che diavolo
di perchè ne devo scegliere una
decidiamo questo qualche più bello di
questo cioè devo sono la monna lisa che
kinnock atac espressione facciale
bellissimo ho sempre vigilato e stare la
monna lisa ragazzi sempre stato il mio
sogno
oh mio dio è la madonna che tragico non
avete è fighissimo apocalypse 2012 the
game ragazzi io già so il cervello a
[ __ ] ve lo dico il caso mai a bello
complimenti senti possono saltare sono
morto sono anche caduto giù sono morto
prima evitino a volte meglio dell'altro
caso elaboratissimo aveva posso morire
in pace not ragazzi stanno arrivando i
maya probabilmente arriveranno anche gli
illuminati adesso
mortacci loro ragazzi non riesco non
resti a suicidarmi la xf siamo morti a
causa della ics sono cose che succedono
christianity the game
e c'è gesù cristo ovvio mi sembra carino
come meglio posso mai giocare un video
che dovevo comandare gesù mi sembra
strano sacro
ok hai ucciso gesù ma perché risorgi
maledizione no
virginia break cos'è ma no a piedi è un
gioco in prima persona è diventato ma
che figo a cazzo ma posso anche sparare
alla madonna permesso fosse entrato rete
tutte fuori te tutti ma posso anche fare
fuori ecco il cartello che effetto fa
sbanda la porta è così che bussano i
veri uomini maledizione fi
buongiorno ho sempre desiderato
combattere di ip
il bello è che bisogna essere
concentrati quando si fosse cose quindi
basta avere l'espressione giusta ragazze
ramstein
certo voi non lo sapete ragazzi ma in
realtà einstein e un metallaro paola
perché ci hanno peso che mi sta sparando
che cazzo fai perché mi spari delle
palle da bowling lloyd stronzo mori
ragazze carica il box si sta cazzo di
gioco che rappa mai a mangiare ciambelle
stronzo ma io io amo questo gioco
ragazzi ma perché
ma perché sa che bella cosa volevo farmi
una doccia ma direi che non c'è più
bisogno porno violence certo mi sembra
giusto ragazzi andiamo avanti così
giorno ragazzi c'è la wish con l'agile
for dead spiego perchè non lo conosce
l'arte which se tu gli spari addosso
tipo ti fa un culo così ma io ci provo
non si è cacciata miracolo vincere
quando gli spari addosso ti sa più bene
perfetto digital tv the game perche
abbiamo ricominciato si spera perché è
stato di fitti buona logica oddio regala
lo slider man telecom c'è la pubblicità
la telecom mi sto cazzo di gioco che
cazzo successo madonna ragazzi che se
full hd 3d è bello non si vedono anche
tanti pixel fantastico tipo super mario
meraviglioso calculus di games vasto
ragazze ti prego limite di hicks che
tende ad ana vi prego regala matematica
già è stato un trauma chiesto cappellone
bene basta la mia reazione quando facevo
le verifiche di matematica o meno la
tentazione era quella di suicidarsi la
stessa cosa o la madonna che sono un
tipo invisibile che figo sono caduto non
ho neanche visto dove son caduto sei
molto pignocco di me la mattina 0 maker
credimi soft primeur tema perché io devo
suicidarmi con delle cose per poi
passare a livello sui cie qual è il
senso di questa cosa tanto tempo fa una
vecchia coppia penny e freddi volevano
dare fondi a loro mal gestito ge.sac non
ideali che ossia vendendo i loro debiti
allora grande amico ben bernake che
presumibilmente si è potuto tutti i
soldi perfetto un po ultima ragazzi
sembra uno slang ha messo tipo attento
però non volta intera list di fermarti
lanciando del loro fondo ma perché devo
devo rubare dei soldi in queste cose che
si può fare ragazzi aiuto losco
lanciando denaro che figo cioè io devo
scorreggiare nelle case distrugge qual è
il senso visto gioco no non mi sono già
mille cosa sto bastardo ad intero cazzo
che ne so io frutta stronzo crepa non
mai bastardo muori mori non crepa ma i
ragazzi sto tipo
c'è chi cazzo è successo ragazzi è
diventato tutto piano anche se c'è
ceschi fico fico schierano vabbè
inserimento ragazzi a che cosa cazzo sto
giocando esattamente education the game
basta perdere tempo studia storia street
estrazioni a premi spazio per iniziare
gli esami perfetto 4,12 viva 36 lorenzo
come faccio a rispondere a devo saltare
al momento giusto
adesso ci ho provato e stato per la
matematica è servita per questo gioco ma
relativamente iraq gay ma come
buongiorno ragazze uscite obama floyd
the game
ci sarà una fine a tutto questo si
qualche bello che sei freud classica
proprio anche staccata dal corpo
perché sia tipo un orgasmo prima di
morire trova la strada più corta
fatemi capire il senso di stare al cos'è
ragazzi sto facendo facciamo un sudoku
questo è un bel è un pene però va bene
uguale
va bene lo stesso anche se un pene cioè
ho vinto se avete bisogno di tutorial
per fare il sudoku chiedete a me son
capaci dimensionate a internet e tris
soltanto a una dimensione bello dice è
difficile soprattutto esploso tutto
vinto fantastico leysin nickname su mio
zio prato fiorito fa perché è perché
affronta la cina sta cosa
no io ho trascinato un cosa capocchiani
da sole perché io sono la bomba io non
sto capendo un cazzo ve lo dico va bene
proviamo l'ultimo ragazzi perché ormai
la mia sanità mentale a [ __ ] peso
cliccato nato hanno tutto a [ __ ] real
non so cosa ho giocato ma va bene ho
vinto a meleto the game
ma veramente che giocassi fatemi madonna
sono tutti i morti che vecchie bello chi
sono io di precisa io sono tutti sono
tutti quanti c'è chi lo nega suicidio di
massa no il mio preferito è morto e
vabbè
l'ultima rimasto vivo
l'ha fatta grande grande cazzo cervelli
sei bellissimo mi ha ucciso st party
sarah palin the game basso ragazzi basta
got milk o mio dio è una milf è sempre
stato sogno della mia vittoria fico
mandare una milf incazzata soprattutto
può essere ma l'intesa l'ultima frase
che ho detto ma come canada the game
canada tutto chiaro andiamo al suicidio
di massa di nuovo perfetto meraviglioso
non ho voglia di leggere ma al tizio mi
fa una paura che non avete idea e pick
roll all de catì sheen non the game
stavolta fermi un attimo la saxe avrei
scommesso la vita la vita sta roba
la madonna lega chiede che cosa bella
che ho visto non seriamente o mio dio
cosa ha riportato alla e ricordi sta
cosa
ma questo è quello di esatto ce le ha
unite tutte praticamente una figata
pazzesca di nuovo ma basta ragazzi basta
mica di nuovo tutto da zero e rotti i
[ __ ] feeling perfetto
dovete spiegarmi che cosa cazzo ho
appena visto spiegatemi love the game
e allora una fine questo gioco prima o
poi nella vita e la madonna il pezzo di
gnocco
io non scapperei a questo punto amico
mio che cazzo fai by così da accidente
maledizione propri altri te che
effettivamente scorta zia se mi ami
davvero dio santo queste cose sporche
ragazzi censuriamo qui ascoltami amore
mio
se mi ami davvero chi seguirà in questo
non mi ha seguito e che [ __ ] narcisismo
the game
la telecamera che mi segue non aver
geniale questa geniale a me così che
moriamo alla fine picchiano sapevo non
ho mai visto lo andava a finire del game
fantastico ragazzi o chiaro la fatica è
finito e stato bello concluso p ragazzi
321 [ __ ] è stato bello un triple
indie games è finito beh cosa epica
ragazzi è stato veramente figo credetemi
non so che cosa ho appena giocato non mi
fate domande non lo so manco york se
addio sun sono morto spiaccicato a terra
è un finale tragico ma va bene uguale
posta che finito il gioco non potevo più
[Applauso]
cieco tecnica che è stato meraviglioso
se magari sfogato finisce perfetto ha
finito quindi ragazzi spero che il video
vi sia piaciuto con questo abbiamo
finito la serie d day the game
abbiamo fatto rai managing the game the
game replay in the game troppo faranno
fa vj the game bravi
infatti talmente tante cose che ho
sentito è piuttosto strumento mi piace
anche a faccia di facebook e come nei
video che la descrizione prestiti
schietti anni cb euro possiamo è caduto
telecomando belle ragazze